ふぁいローン
トレジャーはいそういう意味で今日はですねちょっとドッキリみたいなことをして
みようと思います指で今回ぞくっきりとメインゲットである私本音人骨も気すら
大好きでよろしく入った湯気で今回なんですけども私人骨も芸が外れその功罪に
ドッキリを仕掛けてみようと思います
これ疲れるからやめやっていうけど僕が子供のことがずっと欲しかって骸骨は今回買う
ことができました人骨も系です大輔
可愛いねキーホルダーにもできそうですよね it 系で今回こちらの神滑膜炎の第二
期を使って後輩に終わるドッキリを仕掛けてみると思いますよろしくなっ
よろしくはいというわけなんですけども実験の方法としては見てわかる
と思うんですけども結構ね身長が同じくらいなんですよたんですけど俺が
な大好きでボクシンチョン結構同じくらいなんで僕の私服を大好きがきます
後輩が僕んじゃなかってくると語ってきた瞬間際好きで某所サブしていると多分骸骨
ってバレないですよなので今回はあ先駆けにあったきて魔石がで僕と思って実際に
子どもに話しかけたらなんとビッグ
実は私大好きだったという特急でございまぁ大抵で遊ぶちょっと準備していきましょう
まずは言葉にスク起きたていてあげます
た
トゥデイ
は足が折れちゃう題してないんですねっ
1あーこの僕と同じ体格の骨です僕の骨はため大体こんな感じです大山しっかりこと皆
さん今からお前はがんばるぞ
いっ
どうするひと夏人はず服を着させますよいい恋コーヒー粉だよなパンツで引っかかった
万歳もうもうくれるよねもうすぐ入った方がいいですね俺あとこっちを受け
はこれでもやばいなー鎖骨も何も骨が見えちゃってるよはナイスやこれやでバレちゃう
か mona 鎖骨を隠しましょうすっげー引っかかるのはこれ骨折れ誓っ
追ってない普及できたよぉっ
片側だけにあの意外とは慣れないかも俺がよく着る服を着させろ第一たさんらはたさん
機をスタジャン結構れっぽいと服装
ごめんねもうせございます多いんじゃねぇ
ああ
僕ねちょっと骨バレちゃうんだこれをレっぽいぞ
完全に俺山とほぼ完成形です
奄美見ないじゃんパッ大好きも耳ないかマスクできないよじゃあ卒つづっ扉から入って
くるから引っ張れないよこれマットに俺だ
たったいかんぜ俺だからやっぱた不自然な足の撤廃とかはなくてもこれわかんない
でしょ
これ俺だよハット3見てちょっとターゲットが入ってくる人はこうを登って来て奴隷を
くぐってこうなるんですよねこれでスパッとビオレでしょ
この服装とかほらもうここまでおれだよおれだ完全に俺だってここまできたら
ぎゅううっ
ってなくてほしい相手けど僕の骸骨の影分身の術
数ができたので実際にターゲットを選んでみましょうでよゐこ
コズモせはい上にいる
はいっ
そんなことっ
ん
持っています
に入っています
ん
ています
ヌントペンって俺かと思うんだとか
一緒に乗ったけどよっぽど気に入っだレジャーおかしいなぁ絶対悪さ